[Music]
hello beautiful people make sure you
sign up to patreon because we have our
excuse me doctor doctor here our first
doctor on the show we have an actual
doctor and you'll also be getting 20
extra videos every single month that
don't get posted on YouTube so go over
there in the description links in the
check it out will Bart ever find out if
a woman has three holes or two hadn't
the genitive nerd neurodegenerative
medicine dollars and what my PhD was in
and MD is just MD okay sandy legally
changed it right before was for uses
lecture lecture lecture yeah
but they changed it to two years of
lecture than two years of rotations see
what's a medical squat Stanford he went
to undergrad at Stanford I couldn't get
into Stanford or under grunt do you guys
think it's down there they call him an
OBGYN and not a [ __ ] doctor I don't
think that's professional alcohol in
your parents my uncle passed away in
2007 he had a brain aneurysm he had a
stroke pass and they really treated him
horribly because he didn't speak much
English he was like first first
generations of negative one generation
and he was the one that you know brought
our family here I'm a something stupid
wait there's no such thing as stupid
there's no way you're gonna do that I
have there's no way okay so you're
motivated to be a doctor because your
dad got sick at any given time did you
think maybe you wouldn't have enough
time to where you're a doctor you could
help oh that's that's why I went through
accelerated programs libraries you try
to actually do it like fast enough Joe
that was a legit question that's the
most legit question you've ever asked I
thought it was insensitive I think you
can ask the follow-up question to the
[ __ ] doctor question
Corolla virus is basically like a group
it's it's not really all this is the
corona virus it's it's just basically a
virus that attacks your respiratory
system goes through the ear the ears
nose the mouth that's what the corona
viruses so SARS was a type of corona
virus
it's really not that big of a deal it's
basically like a stronger version of the
flute so do I need to be scared of it or
no you know the biggest thing really
don't talk about with this is that
there's a low death rate like it's ten
percent right 10 percent of the people
infect it's and really honestly the
media is not gonna say this but just be
normal
it's fun your hands people the little
hand don't go to one do you worry that
what we've heard so far from mostly
Chinese media and from the government
over there which is the same thing that
we're not getting a clear picture of
exactly the impact of the viruses I
definitely agree because they were
hiding it from mainstream media and
China went through social media yes I
did this is a medical question okay what
is the point of ass hair just keep your
blood warm oh my but pretty goddamn warm
okay scientifically it's called pile of
erection part you can back me up pile
erection you've heard that studying for
Sciences at you see a little pile of
macro important way to back up what the
[ __ ] Jesus the fun fact is you look at
your left hand you look at your ring
finger men only Oh women too I guess but
figures bigger than your index finger
yeah a lot of testosterone back out a
little bit huh well this shouldn't be
the same ring finger should be longer
than your index finger mine is
definitely not oh wait again that means
you have a lot of testosterone you
really want to jack off all the time
that's why I'm horny fingers tell me
your middle fingers knots must be bigger
than the other fingers yeah buddy
told you
that's right middle middle finger Oh Joe
you have a lot of fact I am horny oh
yeah well that's why you're monogamous
why because your your your ring fingers
way lower than your index finger okay
you're very woman-like sorry how do you
measure testosterone jack off in a cup
my doctor measured my testosterone and
say you broke the Machine hey I think my
papi
[ __ ] that's why I broke [ __ ] fire can I
say tip did did they ask the
ten-year-olds if he did this today
yesterday no and what's he like he's
like Mickey Mouse boys well yeah cuz his
balls have been dropped in Eagle amore
they have dropped he goes on Maury and
who didn't get it pregnant he goes on
Marty and he comes out the audience he's
like this his legs don't even hit the
[ __ ] floor I started jacking off
around fifth grade but there was no car
while shooting I was using this back
massage the mushroom is the massager
okay and it's and it's and it's doing
right underneath the cab oh the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I said this [ __ ] now I have to
[ __ ] stretch juggle because you guys
you get the massager if you just press
it up you don't got to do this [ __ ] you
just looked at him and stuff they were
like there's no sperm like there's no
possible way you could have been
pregnant [ __ ] somebody but here's the
thing like she talked to she just let
that s she talked to a psychologist and
the psychologist is convinced that that
he is the only one that she had sex with
they always say that like stabbing is a
crime of passion but I feel like like
beating somebody with a baseball bat
might be a crime and pastor - yeah
that's true I don't know Debbie can't
you like feel the flesh being and then
with them just like let me yeah I guess
yes I guess yes it's probably more with
the different type of knife like if it
has a serrated it's right it's right
are you definitely feeling more as it
comes out I feel good I would want to
cut like cartilage and ligaments I could
just feel like cutting through all this
that's a lot I don't know if I'm that
strong to rip it through all of that but
I wouldn't mind going in slow just like
[Laughter]
energy over here and then there's like
this would have been okay in Texas now
you step on someone's property steal
their share your [ __ ] your no taxes all
Florida Texas Florida Arizona Texas
Florida Arizona Alabama Texas Florida
Arizona elevate the south that's so
crazy is that he's like he's like this
will protect my home this will protect
me
[Music]